look there's the buyer
or maybe he's just actually saying hi to
the chef why isn't he making the handoff
oh crap he saw us uh
excuse me
oh hey we were just
looking for a place to uh boink
yep
boink that's my preferred term for it as
well
i get it newly engaged kids
enjoy
good good good good good kept our cover
in tech nice work quick professional
thinking out there very quick very
professional detective detective
back on the case
about 10 minutes ago
no i didn't know what to say
yes i know
um
i don't know mom he's my best friend
he's great
yeah i think i am
um i have to go
i will
listen jim
it's midnight so i guess i'm an amazing
human slash genius yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that their belt why
oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape oh my god i'm
shaking i'm definitely gonna cry title
of your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist i will dump
you so hard no please hey it's like it's
really happening okay it's not part of
the heist i promise this is
where you are i love how beautiful you
are
i love your face and i love your butt i
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on i love
how much you pretend to like die hard i
like the second one you don't have to
okay yeah you're
kind and you're funny and you're the
best person i know and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago
will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
hey
this is not halfway
i did the math i have to drive
montclair would have been closer so you
have to buy lunch
what are you doing
i just
i can't wait
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
you're scared
i can't change that yeah but that
doesn't mean i'll never change how i
feel about it i mean i used to be scared
of sushi and now it's my favorite food i
got tuna sashimi from a pharmacy the
other day you shouldn't have yeah it was
very warm i got so sick look can we just
press pause on this conversation i mean
let's enjoy our lives for a little bit
and then maybe the next time it comes up
i'll feel differently okay
no
what i need an answer from you now
like right this minute you could take a
day or a week or maybe a month that's
not a lot of time
i mean that doesn't seem totally fair
well now you know how i feel women don't
have the luxury of waiting till we're 60
and then changing our minds and getting
remarried and having a baby with some
dumb 28 year old come on there's no way
i'm going to be rich enough that a 28
year old is gonna want to be with me
did that help
i don't understand what the big deal is
you're still young we have plenty of
time i know but i don't want to wait
around for two years and then have you
decide you don't want kids cause i don't
want to start over at 38.
start over
like with someone else
case case and all i ever wanted case
station had to get away case station the
vibe in here is really weird i think
they're having a fight no it's not a
fight it's just a devastatingly sad
conversation about whether or not we
should have kids or just start over so
you were totally wrong rosa can you
figure out how to upload uh
cece's dance recital i definitely could
use a pick-me-up um actually funny story
i didn't get it i shouldn't have been so
cocky about my rectangle holding skills
after all
you're not serious are you
you didn't get any of the recital
no i got the teacher introducing them
and then the applause afterwards but not
so much of the middle part come on pam
pam i asked you if you could use the
phone and you swore that you knew how
yeah okay i'm sorry
i'm sure we can get a copy a lot of
people were taping it oh great so we'll
see somebody else's kid with cece in the
background i mean it's really not that
hard to film a video is there i'm
you want to ease up a little bit look
pam i don't know what to tell you i mean
what do i do
it's gone that moment's just gone i
missed it i don't know jim maybe you
should have been there
you're not serious right
i mean how is that fair
i'm in philly these are my days in
philly you've agreed to this you know
what i i don't think you want to start a
conversation with me about what's fair
okay this is way more intense than i
ever i'm not explaining this to you pam
i'm not going over there again i don't
know how awesome we need you
i don't know how to tell you okay
i'm doing everything i can every week to
bring home something for our friends i
am trying to make everything perfect
here okay so that you can have
everything that you want i'm doing this
just for me is that what i'm doing i'm
doing it just for me if that's what you
think then this is a really sad night
but you know what i gotta go okay
yep
we'll talk tomorrow
yep
i'll talk to you tomorrow all right
great i'll talk to you tomorrow
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too i can't wait to spend the
rest of my life with you
ring bearer please bring the rings but i
thought cheddar was sick oh my god
you got the robot there's a robot at my
wedding yeah i felt bad about how
everything went down today so i offered
to help oh that's nice also are you guys
doing the thing where someone gets to
object to this union or is that later
not doing that you've outsmarted me
congratulations okay moving on
do you amy santiago take jake peralta to
be your husband
i do
and do you jake peralta take amy
santiago to be your wife
i absolutely do
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of new york i'd like to announce that
your honeymoon vacation request status
has officially been moved from pending
to approved
you're married you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
anyway
it's like i've waited
[Music]
[Applause]
dance forever
[Music]
[Music]
feel like we're on another level
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
you